bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france cela fait douze jours maintenant
que vous êtes tenus de contrôler le pass
annie terre de vos clients quel bilan
faites vous aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a une application qui
fonctionne plutôt bien
tous antico vide mais qu'à des trous
dans la raquette on n'est pas encore
confronté à la voix la vague de retour
des parisiens de vacances donc on est
plutôt soir à rythme calme donc il rend
possible le contrôle maintenant comment
savoir tous les problèmes qu'on risque
de rencontrer
avec la mise en place de ce pass
sanitaires quel problème est ce que vous
envisagez à la rentrée
il ya une représentante de la république
en marche chez un de vos confrères
il ya une dizaine de jours qui
expliquait que ce pass sanitaires il est
essentiellement mise en place pour
pousser les jeunes à se vacciner en les
contraignant et en compliquant leur
plaisir quotidien et je pense que les
jeunes ils ont déjà eu
ils ont dit ce qu'ils veulent pas se
faire vacciner ils ont déjà la réponse
est là à ce problème ils ont tous des
passes le pass le passé ni terre de
leurs copains et c'est sur leur
téléphone donc
donc ça va être un peu ça va un peu vidé
de sens de la mise en place de ce pass
sanitaires le problème c'est que le sien
personnellement vous avez été confronté
justement à ce type de fraude de pasta
ni terre
on ne peut pas vérifier les identités
noah ce que je peux voir raconté
dernière fois il ya deux petits jeunes
qui arrivent on leur dit qu'on peut pas
les servir parce qu'ils ont pas là lors
pas sanitaire dix minutes après ils
reviennent avec sur leur téléphone a
passé huit heures
alors dans ces cas là voilà en
l'occurrence on leur a dit vous êtes
gentils de mais en fait on pouvait pas
nous prendre pour des cons comme ça
si simplement donc ils sont allés boire
un verre ailleurs mais avec un repas
sanitaire envoyée est-ce que vous goûtez
août et une baisse de la fréquentation
est ce que vous avez le sentiment d'un
subir tout de même même en cette période
estivale
de toute façon chez les personnes qui
sont plus âgés qui n'ont pas encore par
exemple leur deuxième dose etc on a eu
on est une perte de clientèle j'ai
effectivement parce que tous les gens
qui nous présentait
sur l'application tout senti qu vide qui
nous présentait la première dose ça nous
les mettez en non valide donc vous
pouvez pas les servir puisqu'on preuve
faut savoir que quand même on prend un
risque de fermeture administrative de
six jours un
nouveau l'air les les patrons de les
patrons barre donc tous ces gens là on
pouvait pas les servir faut attendre
qu'ils aient leur deuxième dose des
valides
on a un autre trou dans la raquette qui
est ce qu'ils sont une c'est relou qui
ont eu une sérologie positive donc ont
eu en obligations qu'un seul vaccin ça
les sort en négatif aussi surtout senti
qu vide au non valide donc ils sont
obligés de nous présenter le fait leurs
tests de sérologie etc etc et puis là on
va être confronté aussi à l'arrivée
massive des parisiens en retour de
vacances elano terrasson est plein et ça
va être ça va être du sport pour
contrôler alors vous évoquiez à
l'ensemble et les sanctions auxquelles
vous êtes confrontés en cas de non
contrôle des passes annie terre est ce
que vous avez reçu la visite est ce que
vous recevez quotidiennement au fil de
la journée la visite de forces de
l'ordre qui viennent vérifier que vous
exécutiez comme demandé la tâche pas du
tout
pas du tout je pense que les forces de
l'ordre sont occupés à faire d'autres
choses mais on a le on a cette épée de
damoclès au-dessus de au dessus de la
tête alain donc et surtout avec avec ce
risque un jeune qui par exemple à
utiliser le pass d'un de ses amis pour
s'installer en terrasse nous on va
contrôler on va avoir un passe valide je
pense que si on a un contrôle de la
police
il ne va pas présenté va dire qu'il n'a
pas son pass et de nous on va se
retrouver dans ces cas-là en état de ne
pas l'avoir contrôlé alors qu'on leur a
contrôlé voiliers et on va c'est
compliqué et nous aurons porte non
seulement poids du contre et le poids de
la sanction
juste moi ce sera ce sera ma dernière
question comment est ce que vous vous
êtes organisés très concrètement pour
assurer ces contrôles est ce que c'est
une embauche supplémentaire est ce que
c'est du travail supplémentaire pour les
serveurs par exemple c'est du travail
supplémentaire pour les serveurs j'ai
acheté des téléphones en plus pour que
avec l'application téléchargée puisque
de toute façon
on n'a pas le droit de leur imposer
d'utiliser leur téléphone aujourd'hui il
utilise le leurre parfois par plus de
commodité mais en tout cas j'ai les
autres que j'ai acheté parce que c'est
une obligation et c'est eux qui
qui contrôle or normalement devrait
contrôler avant que les gens soient
assis mais par exemple si vous donne
l'exemple de ma terrasse a fait 12
mètres de long avec une contre terrasse
de 12 mètres de long un passage de deux
mètres et un accès par la rue voyez donc
à moins de 1 - de mettre des barrières
sur le trottoirs et d'empêcher les gens
qui juste circulent sans vouloir
s'arrêter chez moi de passer c'est juste
impossible on fait le contrôle à table
quand les gens sont installés on les
sert pas tant qu'on n'a pas validé le
pass sanitaires
c'est quelques heures de travail ont pu
ce sont grosso modo une à deux heures de
travail en plus pour pour le serveur
puisque c'est honda qu'on a pris à peu
près c'est entre 30 secondes et une
minute le temps que les gens sortent
leur téléphone montrent leur passé
anitea etc etc merci beaucoup d'avoir
pris le temps de réagir sur notre
antenne olivier mareuse et aux patrons
de bistrots sur paris